while we wait to hear from Christine
Blasi Ford Brett Cavanaugh's newest
named accuser is speaking out
Julie sweat Nick claims she witnessed
Cavanaugh's alleged excessive drinking
and inappropriate sexual behavior in the
1980s she spoke to show time that is a
division of CBS with her attorney
Michael avenatti Brett Kavanaugh is
going for a seat where he's going to
have that seat on the Supreme Court for
the rest of his life and if he's going
to have that seat legitimately
all of these things should be
investigated because from what I
experienced firsthand I don't think he
belongs saw the Supreme Court Cavanaugh
says the incidents which Julie sweat
Nick has described never happened
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham who
sits on the Judiciary Committee has
defended Kavanagh throughout his
confirmation senator Graham is with us
this morning good morning thank you you
just heard Julie sweat next she spoke
with Showtime why not allow her an
opportunity to speak before this
committee we've been asking her to come
forward and submit to an interview and
if you expect me to believe that Brett
Kavanaugh was a serial rapist one was a
sophomore a junior in high school and he
stopped and never did it again you
expect me to believe that any reasonable
person would go to ten parties for
people being drugged and raped and not
tell anybody about it I don't believe it
she's on the circus Showtime she's been
asked to come before the committee
everything in this man's life the women
who do know him say this is not true
this is not Brett Kavanaugh again how
many people what reasonable person would
keep going back to a party where people
being drugged and raped and not telling
anything not telling anybody about it
not warn their girlfriends subjected
themselves to this kind of terror I
don't believe this so you're fine with
the vote tomorrow no matter what you
hear today here's what I'm looking for
from this for yeah I think the
accusation number three is just complete
garbage
I think the anonymous accusation is
anonymous I think the fifth accusation
was recanted I think the Ramirez
accusation wasn't printed by the New
York Times for a reason I think that
every woman who's ever known
Cavanaugh has vouched for him with being
a good guy everybody that I've known as
work with him 20 years says he's a fine
man I don't think he's a Bill Cosby I
think he's a good decent guy as to miss
Ford something may have happened to her
but I'm gonna look at this as a lawyer
if you brought me this case there's 35
years old and you made an accusation
against Brett Kavanaugh or anyone else
and you couldn't tell me the location
the date and every person you name that
was there said it didn't happen you
couldn't get a warrant all right so
you're former Judge Advocate General a
judge you know defense counsel on
prosecutor so why aren't you doing the
questioning an abductor for Republicans
afraid of what you'll look like I spent
20 years since I've done a case the
politics of this are pretty real I get
five minutes we're going to take a
professional litigator and give them the
time they need to ask questions you got
to admit it looks pretty bad when
there's only Republicans men on that's
on your side I can say it didn't look
bad when I voted for Sotomayor and Kagan
I'm a Republican white guy from South
Carolina when I voted for soda Meyer and
judge Kagan I thought they were
qualified I would never do to them what
they're doing to Cavanaugh I the
presumption of innocence has been
stripped my Democratic colleagues they
sit on this information the accusation
is enough it doesn't have to be
corroborated what kind of world are we
living in you know why I've been
defending
Brett Kavanaugh I think he's a good man
this whole process has been disgusting I
can't vote for somebody from the other
side I will not be part of a Senate that
loses every sense of fairness and
abandons the rule of law we're talking
about the rule of law here except when
it comes to Trump in his nominees
dr. Ford has said she's terrified she's
terrified about Android or just talking
to you guys she's got a camera in her
face before the American people and I've
read her opening statement more than
2000 words in which she says when when
she alleges the judge Kavanagh then in
high school put his hand over her mouth
but it terrified her in it and that she
it has impacted her life why don't you
believe her and yet you have believed
the woman who made an accusation against
senator Al Franken the women who made
accusations I don't I didn't know if I
believed them or not why do you want me
to accept the accusation and not test it
is it okay to ask Miss Ford they're
women who have been abused that never
come forward to those who say if it
really happened she would have said
something there are women who take this
to their grave there are children who
have been abused right now but I am a
lawyer I'm not going to assume that he's
guilty if you can't tell me the year the
month the place and everybody you name
said it didn't happen what am I supposed
to do just abandon every concept we hold
dear in our legal system to get an
outcome I will not do that if you're
expecting me to go ahead and ignore the
fact that she cannot tell me when it
happened where it happened and everybody
she named as that have been there said
it didn't happen I'm supposed to go
ahead and ruin this guy's life when all
the evidence suggests he's not that way
I will not do that I understand that two
men have come forward today Republicans
on the Senate Judiciary Committee have
spoken with them that say they may have
been the man who assaulted dr. Ford I
understand one of them was viewed as not
credible what once Crazy's elune I don't
believe the other one I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna play this game you guys you
don't believe either you know I don't
say something doctor for I can't yes I
don't believe that I don't that's what
to me that would get me off the hook
from having to make a hard decision I
don't know if it's a case of mistaken
identity I do know this was 35 years ago
everything I know about Judge Cavanaugh
suggests he's not this kind of
person miss Ford there's no doubt in my
mind there was some trauma in her life
but we live in a country where you're
presumed innocent and you have to
cooperate accusations of felonies and
there is no corroboration here it's not
that I don't like doctor for looking for
it it's not that I don't understand
women are being abused they are but
sometimes people accuse the things they
didn't do
senator Thank You Senator Lindsey Graham
on the Judiciary Committee will be
watching thank you very much now let's
send it back to Gail and John thank you
Nora